Doug Gottlieb former college basketball
player we have we brought a basketball
hoop over here and McLovin went out
there as well mclubbe and played junior
varsity at Dartmouth and Doug of course
one of the all-time leading assist men
in college basketball history had some
issues from the free-throw line when he
played but he's rectified those he's got
a great shot looks good looks
comfortable
McLovin and dougie fresh are gonna shoot
free-throws shoot ten free-throws and
loser has to go into the fountain here
in DIRECTV
so Doug good to see you good to see you
as well
I see you bringing the Cameron Indoor
Stadium rims as well though you know I
was always wondering about that when you
go into a building and there are certain
places where the rim is tight or the you
know the background is different but
when you did you ever go into a place
and just say I'm not gonna have a good
night because the background or the
aesthetics or the rim every night you
know I was always actually I'm as a very
good shooter that just you know you get
in your own head no this becomes like
stage fright and I became like Rondo
before Rondo you know or you could just
find a way to play without a jump shot
did you see a therapist I did I did like
a sports psychologist I should have done
gone done therapy I mean I think it
would have really really helped you got
like now I do therapy I'm like why it's
like yoga like why didn't I do this but
nowadays you could do it and nobody
would give you grief or make fun of you
I went back then it's like oh my god
he's seeing a therapist no yeah I have a
friend Jay Crouchback who's his sports
he does sports psychology does think
tapping whatever there's that that
athletes do in order to kind of release
your brain from things that hold you
back but anyway to answer your question
yeah I mean there are different types of
you know like if the further back the
background is the lower the hoop looks
you know the closer it is like you know
if you ever go in a high school gym
there's a wall behind it the hoop
sometimes looks like it's 10 1/2 feet
high
yeah and they're all about 10 feet I you
know but do you think Lonzo ball and
Markel folds that's now more mental um
yes Holtz's yes there's a little
physicality lonzo's healthy though
I think Alonso be okay I don't think I
think Lonzo free-throw line there's an
issue there I think Markel faults how do
you shoot 41% from the line well it's a
good question you're asking the right
guy actually mon-sol ball barely and
that's nothing to brag about right like
how do you percent free-throw shooter I
like highschool he's just hold the ball
get fouled and then make the free throws
and win the game right yeah and then you
you just get two you get I there was no
like traumatic it was a traumatic moment
but my first year at Notre Dame
we're playing Rutgers the first ever Big
East game for both teams we're up I
think 17 the second half they make a
comeback
I get fouled airball the first free
throw I make the second so we end up
losing the game and the next day the
late John McLeod who passed away early
this year he has the secretary leaving
message to come down to his office
because that's how he would talk to you
so we go and I sit down you know in his
office and he's got the game on and I
thought we're gonna work on like our
zone offense cuz that's they went to
zone and we screwed up and some
defensive breakdowns he starts look at
the free throws like dougie what
happened here and I was like a scenario
CH
he's like I was like I made the next one
so we went out and he starts he he
called Denny priced Markin Brent price
his dad was his old assistant in
Oklahoma and like John McLeod had never
played basketball and he's sitting there
got my left hand and phone no no but but
it was more than that like I could
actually feel it coming before that I
just but have you ever had an air ball
from the line before no no but I had
plenty after that yeah and then you know
I got in trouble I sat out round here I
went to Oklahoma State and I felt like I
was better and then I get at the
free-throw line at times and then I
would just go like your legs that go you
just feel like numb so it's definitely a
mental thing for most people I think
marquel folds he's basically got what I
have only it's now even worse because
now he's got a hitch you know now
there's the hitch and there's a lack of
belief and I thought they made a mistake
last year drew Halen's a great trainer
but he is not he does not understand you
have to have him somebody who
understands the mental aspects of what
he's going through
and hiding him out in a gym and saying
he's cured like that ain't gonna work
but how does Lonzo ball with a hands-on
dad you would think my part of it I mean
I had a hands-on dad but you know the
other his other brothers can shoot they
have a better looking shot than Lonzo
does yes so how do you get to the point
where you're a starting point guard and
I do like him I just I saw where he
would come down and the defense is
basically saying go ahead
well look he's I think he's gonna become
a solid open three-point shooter but the
mental aspects of the free throw like
that changes everything right you drive
in there you don't want to get fouled
yeah and he's a spectacular freak
athlete you don't wanna get fouled and
you have to get fouled at the end of the
game it hurts your averages it hurts
your ability to create assists he's
already not a great finisher like all of
these things he has to solve the free
throw thing and I think and as much as
the funkiness of it hurts him in game
action that doesn't hurt the release is
fine he can make free throws the way
he's shooting the basketball it's
completely from the neck up and you got
to get somebody who knows how to deep
dive in there and and and understands
how to fix that the NCAA rule here with
Richard where they were calling at the
ridgepole rule rich Paul will LeBron
James held the bridge ball yeah and then
they backtracked a little bit yeah if
you really care about the kids and
you're altruistic and you believe in it
then why are you backing up you know
with this they say honestly scared of
backlash to social media because because
if you look at what they've done all
they've said is okay we're gonna adapt
the NBA PA to be an agent you have to
have a degree or you have to have some
sort of special circumstances and apply
to be an NBA agent in spite of the fact
so really they grandfathered in rich
Paul yeah it's it's corporate America
being very scared of of social media
that's really what it is because there's
I actually what while rich Paul made a
good point in his is op-ed piece that
you know it doesn't mean you're not a
con man just cuz you have a degree like
look all we're trying to do is protect
these players to get the best possible
advice not advice from their uncle or
their aunt or their cousin or their a
you coach somebody who's legit
and reputable okay but create the
perfect system here for these kids if
they want it and we're talking about not
the top guys coming out you want to
protect the kids who aren't getting
great advice you want to test the draft
waters right so house by the way our
guys that rich Paul doesn't represent
okay it's not really the rich Paul yeah
exactly the Christian Dawkins rule
Christian Dawkins was the guy who wanted
to be an agent was a runner and they
just want to try and protect keep those
guys away from the players that's like
the best that they can do but they're
still going to be there of course
they're still well they're still going
to be there bar they can be acting as if
they're an agent because in the way it
works now you can actually agree to
terms with an agent and that person can
advise you and those people specifically
the NCAA is just trying to protect the
play it's it's it's not a great system
why can't I draft you whenever I want to
draft you and you play for me whenever
you want to play for me I love that I
love that idea
you know there is there is problems with
all right you play a really you know you
play Duke North Carolina on a Tuesday
night and then I want you to play though
next week for the Charlotte Hornets like
I can call you up you become my official
minor league is that how you wanna do it
no no once you are drafted let's say
you're a high school player I draft you
and you decide if you want to go play
for me or you want to go to college for
a year then you go for a year and work
on your game and then you come out and
then you're gonna play for my team
you're not playing for North Carolina
one night and then Charlotte the next
night when you're done with your college
career yeah then you know I owe nerd I
own your rights I own your rights yeah
maybe we do it in all the other sports
where we're able to draft rmally we we
do now in baseball once you go back in
you can't you you they they lose your
rights right once you play for a
university they lose your rights until
the next time they can draft you that's
like the Larry Bird had that young he
came out he was drafted got to go back
to Indiana State I don't have any
problem with that
III just think the NCAA and the NBA need
to work together because the idea of
opening up for high school kids is a bad
idea
it makes the league worse makes the
product worse I think College is a great
place and colleges somewhere that you
should welcome more people not less
because it provides more than just like
the education it's the whole lifestyle
and something to fall back on in a
you know basketball family all the
things you don't have as a pro athlete
when it's done as a pro athlete is done
in college when you're done you know
there's place in the administration
there's jobs you can get I'm a big
college sport guys you know but I'm with
you I don't think there should be
anything wrong with a guy you know plays
for UCLA and they can go train and work
out with the Clippers in the offseason
there's no reason you can't you
shouldn't be able to do so in terms of
owning your rights I think that's that's
probably a hard sell considering the I
basketball idea you play really well and
then are you gonna shut it down for the
rest of the year
oh my ankle hurts if you just moved here
would you become a Laker fan or clipper
fan huh if I just moved here so you have
no loyalty no allegiance that's so
that's a great question
probably a clipper fan I mean like look
there they check all the boxes for what
you'd want to have in a team right where
they're like legit excited at the
opportunity of the future there's no
they even those expectations there's not
arrogance with those expectations a
champ ship coach got champ chip you know
figurehead in the front office you have
an owner who's just willing to spend
once the Creed his own entertainment
complex you have great energy with how
they play the other side to it is having
grown up here like the idea that the
Clippers and Lakers are on par is it's
so hard to so hard to fathom you know it
just is the when I was in high school
they had the LA riots so people forget
when Larry Brown's team made the NBA
playoffs they had to play in Anaheim
because the Sports Arena was in the
middle of a war zone you know like you
couldn't there were no clipper fans
nobody grew up a clipper fan you go to
clipper game because it was less
expensive and now the Clippers have a
legit shot I still like what the Lakers
have done
who's better this year I think the
Lakers are still probably another I do
too they have guys that have done it you
know I know Kauai has done it but Paul
George never seemingly healthy and all
those other guys are great first and
second round dudes I want guys that have
done it when it matters I do think
Lakers have more of those guys yeah and
I wonder when this becomes the Davises
team because at some point
Ron has to realize this and I wonder if
he is he the last guy to realize that
this isn't his team anymore on the court
so and it's now Anthony Davis's team
he's supposedly sold Kawhi Leonard and
he sold Anthony Davis son this is gonna
be their team everybody six months ago
it's gonna become the mclovin show right
and we understand that it hasn't yet
evolved into that where's my club he
went in back he's set to stretch get his
gear on and warm up
he's outside there's free throw shooter
yeah he's taking advantage of Doug being
in here oh wow
he's really he's really he knows that he
talked to some trash about you in the
first town he did I would I would say
this I think like well the big unknown
is LeBron and what he's going to be like
he did not move the same last year well
he was out of shape I thought yeah what
I lost a bunch of weight that's awesome
yeah he looks good he looks good but
he's lost weight in the off seasons in
the past so you know Carmelo did this
for years where they super trimmed down
and then they get em be a lifestyle they
they're not they're just I want to know
how he moves at 35 years old no one
moves the same yeah and and a lot of
miles on he's not a regular 35 year old
right yes they have good defenders
around so suddenly you're hiding LeBron
a little bit defensively and how do you
play around him offense and then the
style that he plays where it's a lot of
isolations and create and help that's
not really that's not really how anybody
plays now in the NBA even James Harden
where they do isolate they run a ball
screen to get the rights which like it's
not really how they play so I'm
interested and then yeah Frank Vogel has
never coached him never won a
championship there's a bunch of
different reasons to not totally go
all-in on the Lakers who's got more
pressure LeBron Kawhi Frank Vogel Frank
Vogel yeah thankful boy is he coaching
after next season with the Lakers yes
yes really I just I don't think that the
idea of you brought in Jason Kidd I
think Jason Kidd will get a job I don't
think he'll be with the Lakers oh you
don't think he'll be the next head coach
of the Lakers no maybe but no I
okay I just don't you're not gonna have
three head coaches in three years
don't think so I could be wrong you know
I was right to be wrong I mean they
brought in David Blatt in Cleveland and
I thought Frank was a great hire for
them given what was going on I didn't
need to add to the fire I I didn't I
needed somebody who was just a little
more stable yes not saying anything
incendiary I just wanted I wanted it to
be calm
occasionally Jason Kidd I don't think
brings calmness to that situation yes he
was the head coach agree if he was that
cash but in the role that he's in what
is that role though conduit conduit you
know I've been a head coach I've been a
superstar player okay and because the
one thing Frank has not really coached
he's a star a superstar right play Paul
George was gratitude yeah but he was not
you know when he was then he was partly
was Indiana Paul George yeah I like and
even even now Paul George is not a tough
guy to coach like LeBron's may challenge
he's a child like that's really what the
David Griffin article said was like he's
got a pin yes right but I mean super
super talented and you know everybody
wants to take a shot at winning the
title with him but it's not easy it's
not easy for anybody and I think that
the idea of of Jason Kidd having been a
great player having been a head coach I
think that's the idea of the role that
conduit to all this piece by the way if
you missed any of our interviews from
the mercedes-amg men could go to the Dan
Patrick show app where you can watch and
listen from inside mercedes-amg mancave
mercedes-amg driving performance we'll
take a break if you're watching on
DirecTV audience number channel 239 or
BR live.com it's the showdown this is
what people came to see and it's mclovin
is out there you can see McLovin
shooting his clothes and he did he got
into his basketball gear and he's at the
line and those are back-to-back makes
there with McLovin the bet is 10 free
throws first eight chili oil 10 free
throws and the loser goes into the
fountain here at AT&T yes I got pie in
the face getting a pie shorted a few
times yeah I remember that one when you
bet on for this one Dan I'm gonna go
Doug Doug gets a clutch Jean when he hit
that three in Houston get one chance
the first clutch shot he's good that is
but you've got a great-looking shot
you've got nice follow-through nice arc
I mean he looks great but you know what
when the game's on the line you got it
with the pie oh boy I was so proud of
that moment very good very good set I
had to give the pie to somebody in the
crowd and say put it behind your back
we're gonna get a team picture here and
friends like you guys who needs any I
know I know I know we'll have the free
throw contest coming up next year with
Doug and McLovin okay we're outside the
Richmond studios on the campus of
DIRECTV AT&T and Doug Gottlieb against
McLovin this is ten free-throws and then
we have a fountain here and I just
checked the water yeah warm I'm gonna
guess it's around 65 degrees in that in
the fountain the loser gets a baptismal
dip into the fountain you shoot McLovin
won the coin toss Doug will shoot five
and then McLovin shoots and then Doug
then McLovin over 100k one number two
two for three okay well actually been
talking us better when I was talking oh
man one for one
McLovin he just did kind of shorten give
it a good follow through three McClement
fire right now for McLovin Dartmouth JV
this is so nerve-racking five just makes
not good not good here's Doug two four
five a lot of here
three four six it's like baby stuff it
doesn't it it's all gonna come down to
ability to eight five four eight close
the deal top six four nine you need this
one Doug got at seven for that and fruit
nice to go down McLovin for Ellison
Coffee is for closers
baby always four wins win three wins
Andrew for three rings hit the second
one seven can't miss if you won seven
said one more way yeah this is over this
is it a lot of people are shooting free
throws this is it
wow that's really kind of you love doing
a Romani look away shot there four more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]